we can get live input audio and video
directly into our app by using an API
called getusermedia this is a simple
example where we just call getusermedia
passing it some constraints that say we
want video and then we assign the
resulting stream to a video element in
the page of course this just gives us a
rectangle with live video input we
probably want to do something with it if
we want to grab snapshots like if we
want to implement a camera application
we can do this with a canvas context and
draw image whenever we want to take a
snapshot we simply grab the image from
the video and we draw it to the canvas
withdraw image of course a canvas is
different than an image you can't
directly copy a canvas and paste it
somewhere else or download it to your
hard drive or post it to your social
networks or any of the other typical
user flows centered around images but it
turns out canvas has a handy function to
encode itself as an image the canvas to
data Earl method here instead of
displaying the canvas itself we're
copying the canvas contents as a data
Earl to the source of an image tag and
if you want to save these images to the
Mobile's local storage you can do that
too by forcing a download of a link
using a download attribute on an anchor
element this isn't really downloading
the data per se it's encoded in the link
itself so you're not really transferring
things over the network